bene tutti i ragazzi e per me lui deve
solo video sono poi genio oggi siamo
grati un video sui rockets league dove
vi racconto la mia vita incredibile ho
fatto video myspace balle uscirà a
gennaio guardatelo perché molto film
spoiler o un incredibile
allora ragazzi racconta di una cosa
molto particolare che mi è successa
nella vita che sono le violazioni di
domicilio non scherzo ma cosa molto
simile però diciamo che allora io sono
una persona molto particolare vuol dire
che quando sono diventato conosciuto era
iniziata succedermi cose che implicano
perché sono le conseguenze di avere
tanti panne ovvero la gente che mi
riconosce per strada
quello sembra pietro che sono successe
sempre tante cose molto particolari se
succedono le persone conosciute no c'è
una cosa in particolare che a maggior
ragione io sempre
sono riuscito a non sopportare nella
maniera più assoluta che sono quelli che
cerca di capire dove abiti allora
partiamo da da quando abitavo a torino
quando abitavo a torino quindi io ho
visto di quella casa tutta la mia vita
nella casa ma mappano che questo mappano
di caselle questo paesino piccolo alle
porte di torino ho sempre vissuto in
questo paesino sin da quand'ero piccolo
quindi quando ho iniziato a diventare
conosciuto sulla piattaforma di youtube
ero nella mia cameretta questa che
vedete che sta in realtà ma parli
gazzelle sottoli nostro nome perché
bellissimo e quindi quando ho iniziato a
diventare conosciuto diciamo che abitavo
in un condominio dove c'erano anche
tanti altri ragazzini a scuola usciva
fuori spesso la domanda ma dove capitava
vj e gli amici che abitavano gli amici
capitavano nel mio stesso quando mi
diceva il mio vicino di casa abita qui
morale della favola la gente ha iniziato
a citofonare mi sotto casa
tante volte io avevo già un milioncino
di iscritti ancora abitava in quella
casa lino e la gente mi citofonava di
continuo cioè voglio dire che io tutti i
giorni dove non rispondevo io ti può
dare a mia mamma mio papà dicendo no non
c'è in spiaggia in piemonte e io cosa
devo fare io voto a fare i miei video
senti questo citofono e ogni volta che
sentivo citofono non era un oh mio dio
vabbè dai
l'altro ban ki se ne frega no io me la
vivo proprio male come la vivevo grazie
a dio non esiste più della vita
normalissima questa cosa malissimo
perché ogni volta che citofonavano il
mio cuore iniziava a battere proprio in
una maniera incredibile come se mi
avessero puntato una pistola capito e
non c'era motivo perché non era una cosa
normale mi citofono a casa però allo
stesso tempo era logica come cosa non è
che c'era niente di male alla fine non è
che succedeva nulla visita fenomeno e
basta
però il mio cuore reagiva tipo mister
citofonando sono dei fan
non so per quale motivo è e quindi io ho
sempre vissuto questa cosa molto molto
molto molto male non ero a mio agio
nella mia non sono mai stato a mio agio
quando gli fanno comunque le persone
invadono la tua privacy insomma la tua
privacy che non vuol dire soltanto il
domicilio e vuol dire anche con i suoi
magari una relazione e i fan vanno a
scrivere alla tua ragazza tuo ragazzo
dipendere che personaggio pubblico è una
cosa che ho sempre odiato cioè tu sei un
mio fan una mia pal mio fan usa vai a
scrivere la persona con cui sto già fi
a meno che quella persona non sia un
personaggio pubblico tipo sanabili e
sascha ma la cosa che mi ha sempre dato
più fastidio di tutte è stata quando
vuoi quando la gente mi veniva
citofonare a quell'eta da quella cosa
assurda
ora vi racconto questo è successo quando
mi sono trasferito a milano sono
successi vari aneddoti
partiamo acqua milano sono stati in tre
case attualmente sono nella mia terza
nella prima casa a milano facevo molta
attenzione a non far vedere quando in
casa vano era una casa in pieno centro
quindi era anche molto difficile questa
cosa ma facevo particolarmente
attenzione a non entrare in casa però mi
hanno trovato lo stesso e come mi hanno
trovato lo stesso non ci credete mai
nella mia prima casa a milano non c'era
la cucina non c'è la vicina una casa non
c'è non c'è la cucina ordinavo il cibo
anche a pranzo riina voci vacanza ci
ordina voci ordinavo il mio cibo e avevo
scoperto in quel periodo
le applicazioni per ordinare il cibo
online non facciamo riferimenti se no la
regia stile libero quindi io ho messo il
mio nome e cognome nel nell'app di just
eat da ho gestito i tempi ordinato una
pizza una bufala arriva tipo che
consegna la pizza aveva suo figlio saprà
suo figlio ma non era il tipo che
consegna la pizzera il proprietario
probabilmente al ristorante era un
signor abbastanza anziano mi suonano
ciao è arrivato tu la pizza ios siro io
ho pagato solo una pizza non il bambino
no no lui è mio figlio e voleva fare una
foto con te adesso io dico ma tu c'hai
[Musica]
non ho detto sì ma c'è un file sharing a
capire che un dom il chelsea se io sono
a casa mia non è che mi puoi bussare
alla porta chiedendo mina forno non
esiste che poi questa cosa qua io ho
visto che sul web c'è tanta ignoranza è
vista quasi come cattiveria e ma uno
viene a casa tua non poi la foto no ma
sei pazzo è successa una cosa del genere
anche a gambo dsquared non mi ricordo
che avevo visto un suo video due parole
di stalla vagheggiando aveva comprato
casa nuova e c'è uno dei fan che
venivano citofono agli casa chieda di la
foto ragazzi sbagliatissimo è
sbagliatissimo c'è una persona che tra
l'altro non è che dici a un fan quindi
va bene
no è una persona che ha tanti fan non è
che non fa la foto se gliela chiedete a
casa sua per cattive non è cattiveria e
che se tu la fai con lui poi in arrivano
mille
ok arrivano mille perché quella persona
diciamo ora fatto la foto fa niger com'è
che l'hai fatta e sono andato a casa sua
e dove abita e abita quale ciao quindi
capo aveva fatto poi un video dove
spiega questa roba diceva ragazzi io non
è che posso fare le foto con voi sia
finita sulla mia casa è sbagliato perché
poi se io faccio una foto con voi poi
non cada anche se mi dicono gite dove
abito sì sì seguo katz e quindi poi si
presentano mille persone che vogliono
chiedere la foto autografo video per la
famiglia e per il cane e diventa
invivibile gabbo poi tratto quando hai
fatto stupido era stato anche
etichettato come uno che è ma te ne
freghi dei fan ma ragazzi ma avete idea
di che cosa vuol dire quando qualcuno vi
sono in casa è orribile va bene tutto va
bene fermarsi quando si picchiano le
fotografata che è una cortesia anzi
anche un piacere oltre che questa sia
perché dunque vuol dire che c'è gente
che stima il tuo lavoro che cosa ho
fatto
da allora io non mi chiamo più lorenzo
studi quando ordine online mi chiamo
giacomo mi chiamo giacomo frizzi e
questa è stata la prima volta cambio
kasami citofona a un certo punto dopo
mesi una ragazza ciao ciao ho scoperto
dove abiti dai tuoi video e io ma come è
possibile
io non ho mai fatto vedere video
dell'esterno di casa mia si si lo so
però tu una volta in un torrido hai
fatto vedere il tuo balcone e quindi io
sono andato a scandagliarne tutti i
balconi di milano ci ho messo tipo di
tre mesi fino a che non ho trovato il
tuo dopodiché sono venuta
citofonare e io ero tipo un po vabbè
propongo e la cosa particolare di tutto
questo che tu dici vabbè già l'acqua è
già qua è pazzia
già questa è una pazzia che diceva sei
veramente una persona pazzo ma non è
tanto quello io abitavo al terzo piano
ma di piani nel mio condominio ce
n'erano tipo 78
quindi tu come hai fatto capire che il
mio era il terzo piano è perché in quel
video provato a capire l'angolazione del
piano voi capite che in quel video non
si vedeva fuori dal balcone si vedeva il
balcone quindi il balcone coperto la
balcone sopra comme faje delle il mio
balcone ho cercato di capire quale fosse
l'altezza e o ho capito è quello più o
meno tutto poteva vi darò secondo al
terzo piano ed è venuta al citofonato al
campanello in casa pensa se la cosa
fosse contraria ci pensa se io avessi
citofonato ad una ragazza dopo averla
stricker ata così tanto ho visto sarah
in carcere però andiamo avanti regalò a
arriviamo al culmine di questa cosa
sempre nella stessa casa dopo un po di
tempo e io mi trovo una lettera sotto la
porta ho detto mi aveva fatto casino e
miei vicini non hanno sentito poi io
faccio sempre attenzione a non prendere
casa io non ho case con vicini
ok quindi io non ho vicini mai proprio
per evitare che uno che mi sentano 2
proprio per riuscire a registrare anche
a tarda notte in modo tale da non
sbagliare qualcuno quando io prendo una
nuova casa la prerogativa numero 1
requisito numero uno di questa casa non
deve avere vicini né sopra né sotto nel
dietro ne ha davanti mai guardo c'era
scritto ciao lorenzo siamo due tuoi fan
siamo fidanzati dall'altro siamo
conosciuti grazie a te va bene roba del
genere sappiamo che abiti qua perché va
beh insomma riattivi stalker ismo
abbiamo anche sentito mentre registravi
ma non abbiamo voluto disturbarti quindi
abbiamo scritto questa lettera per
favore contattaci sono scappato in
guatemala
ho vissuto delle esperienze brew mi
hanno formato queste esperienze però
bombe
immaginatevi voi non potete neanche
uno che in casa non c'è non ha più
privacy ragazzi orribile non mi si
apposta dal balcone opposto col binocolo
per guardarti ricevuto la paura per un
periodo che qualcuno sia da ragazzi non
scherziamo società altro mi ricordo che
io quando ero più piccolo quindi non
facevo youtube volevo andare a trovare
più di pai e quindi mi ero impegnato più
o meno per cercare di capire dove
abitasse in italia ora che sono
cresciuto ho capito quanto questa cosa
fosse andata una cagata e ho detto mamma
ma io veramente ho pensato una roba del
genere sono proprio da buttare nel
cervello però ci sta perché ero piccolo
no quindi non ne faccio una colpa però
ai 50 anni leggi che io ho ordinato una
pizza non mi portare tuo figlio in casa
tutte le normali però vabbè dai ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto basta che io
questi episodi iscritti al canale
schiacciate la campanella non quella
della mia porta quella sopra sotto e lo
è come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video belle ragazze
[Musica]